chronovirus coverage now it's being  called v-day in the uk  now the first western country to begin  vaccinations for coveted 19.  ninety-year-old margaret keenan was the  first person to receive the vaccine in  the uk this morning there she is  the first 800 000 doses are going to the  most vulnerable  hospital and nursing home workers and  the elderly the vaccine is given in two  doses  21 days apart officials call the mass  immunizations  a light at the end of a very dark tunnel  amazing to see this tremendous shot in  the arm for the entire nation  but we can't afford to relax now britain  is the hardest hit country in europe  over 61 000 people there have died from  covet 19.  that is one of the highest in the world  per capita even higher than the us  the uk has secured 40 million doses of  the pfizer vaccine that is enough for 20  million people  the u.s has ordered 100 million doses  that is pending  fda approval